Yeah,
I think one of the great things I love
about San Francisco is so fun.
I just love the typography offer.
It was a great walk into and you just,
you can walk around San Francisco and
suddenly you know,
you,
you get up and one of the hills and
you're looking over the city and you're
just go a completely different aspect.
You couldn't believe that you,
you're,
you're just a marriage,
don't to this.
So when you can just see all over the
place,
you dip down into the,
into the skin to get Kinda cool
neighborhood you've never seen before
and it's obviously because of it's
always,
again,
it's changed me.
All American cities are changing because
of maybe,
maybe San Francisco.
I was going to say that affluence is as
driven out the ash to San Francisco.
We used to go there and you're used to
and know the economically disadvantaged.
I used to fly to San Francisco and
people used to go there for the vibe and
the whole hippie thing and stuff like
that and but I'm not.
It's the recession might kind of
ironically might restore the glory of
San Francisco and away know and stop
being this kind of Yuppie Paradise,
which is kind of just become the whole
silicon.